Joanna, we need your expert eye on this next story
because it comes from Real Homes.
They're reporting that there's one design trend in 2022
that they're gonna flip a switch on.
And that's shiplap.
Boo!
Some designers said that the ship has sailed on shiplap.
It's time to try something different.
A wallpaper and said.
Now, Joanna, you literally changed shiplap for everybody.
You put it on the map.
You made it a material we all...
I just did it in a room,
and it's my favorite thing I've ever done in my life.
I think shiplap, you know, when you think about it,
this is something that's been in homes
for over a hundred years.
So to me, trend again, I'm not a trendy person.
That's what when you get stuck in a trend,
it's like, oh, I like more of that idea of timeless.
Back to the basics.
So when I think about shiplap or even hardwood floors,
or certain kinds of tile that have been around
for over a hundred years,
I just don't think that's really something
that ever goes out.
Now I get that it's been done a lot
in that farm house kind of genre,
but what I think the trend is is seeing
how that's gonna cross over to multiple different styles.
Whether it's modern or minimal,
you're gonna see it kind of do it's thing
in all different kinds of styles
because it's a classic material.
It's how they used to build homes.
So to me, it's like, you can't.
It's timeless.
It's not gonna go away.
I love it.
Also to your point, it goes with everything.
And if someone says a drywall or a shiplap,
there's no question.
Yeah.
And you can hang it.
vertical, you can be creative with how you install it,
and that's the fun part is seeing how it's evolving.
And I like that.
All right, and it wouldn't be
a proper Drew's News without the snacks.
You know, we've always got some Magnolia approved grub today
in what we call Food News.
(audience applauds)
What is this?
Wow.
Mac and cheese sandwich.
What?
So now these are from the Cheddar Truck.
They've made us these cheesy sandwiches
made of Joe and Aya's collective dreams.
It's a classic grilled cheese with two types of cheeses,
but get ready for this twist.
There is Mac and cheese in here too.
So thank you, Cheddar Box for literally sending me
right over the edge.
I will say if there was any debate
about whether or not there was a God or not,
you've gotta try this mac and cheese sandwich.
And I think it solved the mystery.
Oh my God, there's cheese on the outside.
Cheese everywhere.
This is my dream.
Holy moly.
Drew, you managed to make mac and cheese worse for me.
By putting it in a grilled cheese, I'll never forgive you.
This is so good.
You guys are just so amazing.
(upbeat bright music)